deswegen frage ich Karla Rems mal die
das darf ich verraten die jüngste hier
in der Runde ist die ich auch schon ein
paar Jahre kenne und die ich sehr
schätze und ich gerne fragen würde Frau
remser müssen sie sich das auch anhören
von ihren Eltern was weil die Klage von
Linus nemann die kenne ich euch geht's
allen viel zu gut müssen sie sich das
auch
anhören ich glaube nicht unbedingt weil
ich glaube schon dass also sein meine
Eltern Seins andere Menschen aus der
Generation meiner Eltern genau wissen
welche Herausforderung auf uns zukommen
und dass das Herausforderungen sind auf
die wir gerade noch nicht so richtig die
gesellschaftlichen und politischen
Antworten haben die aber kommen werden
wenn wir so tun dass oh wir müssen nur
warten und der Fortschritt kommt schon
weil das ist ja eine Illusion das haben
die letzten Jahre Jahrzehnte auch
gezeigt der Fortschritt alleine wird
beispielsweise die Klimakrise nicht
lösen und das ist eine riesige
gesellschaftliche Herausforderung na ja
für für uns sage ich jetzt mal unsere
Generation also Linus Neumann ist ein
bisschen jünger Laguna und ich sind so
fast die gleiche Liga m
obwohl ich deutlich älter aussehe gebe
ich gerne zu aber für uns hat das
funktioniert also für uns hat dieses
aufstiegsversprechen funktioniert sie
glauben dass es in den 10 Jahren
schlechter gehen wird als
heute wenn wir jetzt so weiter Maen wie
bisher dann ist es relativ klar da kN
man sich die Klimakrise anschauen das
ist nur ein Bereich und das ich spreche
jetzt auch nicht nur für mich wir können
uns anschauen aber sie persönlich Frau
REM wird mich erstmal interessieren sie
persön als Karla remsm haben Sie das
Gefühl ihr Leben wird in 10 Jahren
schlechter sein als es heute
ist ich glaube das weiß man ja jetzt
noch nicht also das Gefühl mir geht um
das Gefühl wir wussten es ja auch nicht
aber wir wir wir glaubten fest daran
dass es morgen besser wird als heute ich
glaube daran dass es besser werden kann
wenn wir was dafür tun wenn man wenn wir
jetzt alle still sitzen bleiben dann ist
sehr sehr klar dann wird's nicht besser
dann wird's auf jeden Fall schlechter
und ich glaube das ist ja was das zeigt
sich auch immer wieder und wieder wenn
man irgendwie junge Menschen befragt
nicht nur in Deutschland auch auch
irgendwie in anderen europäischen
Ländern das für ein Großteil und das ist
ganz spannend es Sie davon ausgehen dass
die Lebensbedingung in den Ländern wo
sie wohnen in 10 Jahren schlechter sein
werden aber nicht unbedingt Ihr
persönliches Leben weil da dieser
grundsätzliche Glaube an oh wir können
doch alle noch irgendwie alles schaffen
der ist noch da obwohl eigentlich klar
ist dass die gesamtgesellschaftlichen
Bedingungen überhaupt nicht darauf
ausgelegt sind sondern dass die uns
gerade eher dahinbringen die soziale
Ungleichheit wächst wir haben keine
Antwort auf die Klimakrise geopolitische
Konflikte wo wir nicht wissen wie es
weitergeht äh über die KI Risiken haben
wir glaube ich andere Experten in der
Runde die noch drüber zu sprechen werden
und dass wir da eine junge Generation
haben die total realistisch darauf
schaut und sagt ja wenn gerade haben wir
keine politischen antworten wenn sich da
nicht was ändert dann wird in 10 Jahren
schlechter aussehen als jetzt wobei man
sagen muss das ist ein total konstantes
Phänomen also ich will nicht sagen ich
will es nicht leugnen dass wir die
Klimakrise haben aber dass man sein
eigenes Leben dass man positiv in seine
eigene Zukunft schaut und negativ in die
Zukunft des Landes das gibt seit den ja
bevor Sie ausführlich antworten Frau wie
wie geht's ihnen glauben Sie dass es ihn
den 10 Jahren besser geht als heute mir
persönlich ja Ihnen ganz persönlich also
ich sehe zwar jünger aus als sie bin
aber nicht sehr viel jünger ich denke
aber trotzdem ja ich glaube für mich
selber denke ich hoffe ich mal das
gesundheitlich vor allem wir sind jetzt
im Alter vor uns kommen jetzt dann die
Gesundheit wir bitte Sie sind da raus
ich bin
jits doch ich grundsätzlich für mich
denke ich schon dass es in 10 Jahren
besser ist als jetzt okay wie ist bei
ihn Herr Laguna na ja sagen ne sie
werden nächstes Jahr glaube ich 60 haben
sie genau 10 soit nächstes Jahr 70 da
muss noch viel Fortschritt passieren
damit es mir immer besser gehtil dann
kommt das Alter um die Kurve aber ich
glaube schon ich bin da ein
grundoptimist weil die Welt eigentlich
die letzten paar hundert Jahre immer
besser geworden ist ne also seit den
Zeiten der Aufklärung ne wenn man das
natürlich hoch zooomt ne gab es unten
immer Verschiebung wo es mal Einzel
Betroffene oder auch Länder schlecht
hatten eine ganze Zeit lang es ging auf
und nieder aber seitdem wir die
Wissenschaften haben die war
ja geht uns immer besser und ich wüsste
nicht warum das jetzt aufhören sollte
auch wenn wir diese Krisen haben ich
kann mich übrigens noch erinnern als ich
so in ihrem Alter war da gab's auch
diese Krisen Waldsterben Ozonloch und
alles mögliche da
gab's Prognosen dass die Welt
untergeht das
spannende so drastisch formuliert aber
ich kenne ein Interview von ihr wo sie
sehr drastisch formuliert hat sie sagte
dieses Gerede von den polikkrisen die
wir angeblich haben Klima und Inflation
und Kriege und das ganze Ding ich kann
es nicht mehr hören weil es geht
komplett an dem vorbei was eigentlich
immer war also ich bin 46 Jahre alt ja
in den 80er Jahren haben wir
gelesen die Wolke sie erinnern sich noch
das Buch das muss man sich mal
reinziehen genau die Wolken radioaktiver
vollut ich bin in Bayern aufgewachsen
wir hatten wirklich in den 80ern ständig
Angst dass es zu einem nuklearen Krieg
kommt und wir sind direkt an der Front
dann Waldsterben dann das Ozonloch wir
verbrennen alle live auf der Erde die
die Hungersnöte unserer Großeltern also
ich ich ich finde also es ist es gibt
einem vielleicht ein Gefühl von
historischer Bedeutung zu sagen so
schlimm wie jetzt war es noch nie und
wie gesagt nicht Klimakrise ist ein
anderes Thema aber ich glaub W ganzeau
wenn man das ganze aufzieht dies Krise
macht man gleich ein neues Wort drauß
und so tut so historisch so schlimm wie
jetzt war es noch nie dann tut man zwei
Sachen erstens man gibt sich irgendwie
ein egooboost weil okay es ist zwar
schlimm aber immerhin sind wir live
dabei W historische Bedeutung aber
zweitens passier aber zweitens gibt man
sich das Gefühl der Entmachtung weil es
hat noch nie jemand was sowas schlimmes
geschafft
also bringe ich sie endlich mal zum
Lachen ja aber so wir können es quasi
nicht schaffen und wie gesagt ich sag
immer sich mit seinen Großeltern
unterhalten oder Generation vor uns es
stimmt einfach nicht auch sie haben
nicht in ihrer Jugend gedacht dumm die
dumm alles wird super in der Zukunft
sondern sondern Stichwort Kalter Krieg
inflationskrise hier was diese
umfrageerte ne dass man sein eigenes
Leben für einigermaßen positiv in die
Zukunft schaut aber für die Gesellschaft
nicht das gibt es seit den 60er Jahren
ich mE überleg mal vor 100 Jahren ne
1923 so da war gerade der erste
Weltkrieg rum ne da war die die eine
riesen Epidemie die Spanische Grippe die
Viertel der europäischen Weltbevölkerung
glaube ich dahinerafft hat es kam eine
Hyperinflation der Hitler kommt an die
Macht ein paar Jahre später der Zweite
Weltkrieg fängt an ne also da kann man
sagen also die hatten seriös Probleme
und irgendwie haben sie es ja
hingekriegt ne also da sind wir trotz
der riesenpreme die wir vor uns haben
glaube ich noch also noch lange nicht
gut ich muss ja vorhin so lachen weil
ich dachte das wä W perfekter ZDF Film
jetzt im ZDF die Apokalypse
Mitternacht werbar aber noch mal die
Frage vielleicht an Herr Neumann und
auch an an karmer woher kommt denn dann
dennch dieses Gefühl und das muss man ja
ernst nehmen dass uns der Glaube an eine
gute Zukunft dermaßen verloren gegangen
ist woher kommt das was glauben
Sie vielleicht
K schauen
gerne ich glaube das gerade wenn wir uns
jüngere Generation anschauen haben wir
natürlich nichts destotrotz und ich
glaube muss ja auch gar nicht sagen das
ist jetzt dieser historische Moment und
so schlimm war es noch nie aber eine
extreme Häufung von sehr einschneidenden
Erlebnissen also gerade wenn wir uns die
coronaapandemie anschauen die mit den
ausgangsbeschränkungen mit irgendwie
krassen Restriktionen was Schule
Universitätsalltag irgendwie angegangen
hat ja noch mal ein Ausmaß hat was sich
so tief in die Lebensbereiche der Leute
reingezogen hat dann irgendwie kurz
danach der russische Angriffskrieg in
der Ukraine Energiepreise die irgendwie
dazu führen dass Menschen sich gefragt
haben ja ich kann nicht mehr richtig
heizen das ist ja schon sehr sehr
existenziell und on top kommt auf jeden
Fall für eine junge Generation die
Klimakrise als eine Krise wo wir wissen
es gibt guten Grund eine gewisse Form
von Hoffnung zu haben weil wir wissen
dass die Klimakrise real ist wir wissen
dass sie schlimm ist aber wir wissen
auch wie wir sie bekämpfen und wir haben
Lösungen dafür nichtsdestotrotz sind
alle Prognosen gerade diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass wir die 1,5°ad
Grenze einhalten extrem klein und da ist
es real ja sehr sehr begründet sich
genau deswegen auch Sorgen zu machen
gerade weil eben der politische Wille
obwohl er so oft kund getan wird ja
absolut vorne und hinten nicht ausreicht
und auch immer wieder Versprechen
gegeben werden und ich glaube das ist
ein ganz großer Knackpunkt dass die
Krisen so klein geredet werden und dass
gerade im Bereich Klima so getan wird
ach wir können das doch alles irgendwie
schaffen und da wird sich auch nichts
ändern und damit tut man so als wäre die
K Krise ganz klein dann braucht man ja
auch gar keine größeren Veränderung und
ich glaube da ist den Leuten nach
Hitzesommer nach Hitzesommer nach
Waldbrand nach Waldbrand nach
Überschwemmung astren klar dass das
vorne hinten nicht reicht ich würde mal
eine andere These Wagen ist es so dass
wir Krisen in Wahrheit viel größer reden
statt sie klein zu reden ich habe auch
da wieder Florence gup Diemer zuständig
ist für sehr prägnante Bilder heute
stecken wir die sagt sinngemäß früher
haben wir um 20 Uhr die Tagesschau
geguckt da gab es eine Viertelstunde
Apokalypse und danach war auch noch das
Wetter schlecht aber dann war
Feierabend heute stecken wir ich zitiere
sie jetzt wörtlich den ganzen Tag mit
dem Kopf im Sand von Gaza und das stimmt
das was dran ist ist das eines der
Themen dieser dieser mediale Overkill
der uns von morgens bis abends
suggeriert pass auf es es es ist alles
katastrophal und sozusagen ignorierend
dass Pessimismus und und Skandalisierung
und Katastrophenmeldung auf
Katastrophenmeldung natürlich auch
längst ein Geschäftsmodell geworden ist
ich also ich würde auf diese man kann
nichts machen Perspektive ein bisschen
eingehen weil das Phänomen in der
Psychologie nennt sich so erlernte
Hilflosigkeit also wenn man merkt ich
kann da nichts dran tun ne das es ändert
sich nichts ich ich bin ohne
Einflussmöglichkeit das steuert in in so
eine depressive Haltung das ist das
Gegenteil von Optimismus weil es gibt ja
auch gar keinen Anlass ja also wenn man
keine Selbstwirksamkeitserwartung hat
und das ist das das ist ehrlich gesagt
das einzige was mich in Deutschland
gerade fertig macht ist dass wir ja in
Anbetracht einer
einer fürchterlichen Klimakrise ja und
sagen so schaffen wir jetzt das so und
so viel gradziel oder nicht ne und ja
schaffen wir nicht aber die Konsequenz
aus ja versuchen wir lieber gar nicht
erst statt zu sagen so was hätten wir
denn zu verlieren schlimmstenfalls
schlimmstenfalls ja rollen wir jetzt
massenhaft Wind und Solarenergie aus und
Batterien und haben irgendwie
angenehmere Verkehrssituation in den
Städten geringeres herzinfarktr Risiko
ne also wir haben so viele geile Sachen
die die wir die wir jetzt machen können
einfach nur und und wir haben sogar noch
einen ziemlich guten Grund nämlich
vielleicht geht der Planet oder
vielleicht duldet der Planet uns dann
weiter auf seiner Oberfläche ja das das
aber wir sagen so ja boah wer weiß ob
das stimmt ne wer weiß ob wir da was
machen können vielleicht doch lieber
erstmal noch mal eine paar Generationen
Diesel bauen und diese wir hten ja
überhaupt nichts zu verlieren es GB
jetzt nicht so das Risiko einer
Fehlinvestition in klimaschonende
Technologien das Risiko besteht ja nicht
aber aber es es erscheint mir aus dieser
erlern in Hilflosigkeit zu kommen dass
man das Problem gar nicht mehr angeht
oder dass man nicht mehr den Unterschied
erkennt zwischen einem Problem was man
angehen kann und einem dass man nicht
angehen kann Gaser ist für mich
persönlich ein Problem an dem werde ich
nichts ändern können ne das übrigens
begleitet mich auch schon D habe ich
auch schon früher als Kind in der
Tagesschau gehabt ne da da war also da
das ist etwas was geeignet ist mich zum
Verzweifeln zu bringen ich kann aber
natürlich ähm
ähm in der in dem Wandel und den neuen
ökonomischen Möglichkeiten die sich
bieten durchaus Perspektiven sehen sehe
ich die in
Deutschland
nein aber können wir noch mal über
dieses mediale auch noch mal sprechen
weil ich habe schon das Gefühl oder
frage ich hat das was damit zu tun sie
haben ein ganzes Buch über die Frage
geschrieben wie gestalten wir Zukunft
wie gewinnen wir sie nennen es glaube
ich
Zukunftsfähigkeit also diese
intellektuelle Beweglichkeit die man
braucht um sich auch Zukunft vorstellen
zu können und sie sagen sogar Depression
ja ist eigentlich in Wahrheit das fand
ich ein sehr interessanten Gedanken die
Unfähigkeit sich die eigene Zukunft
vorstellen zu können das finde ich einen
sehr guten Gedanken also was man schon
sieht ist dass seit dem Jahr 2000
passieren so ein paar Entwicklungen
gleichzeitig die sich dann vielleicht
gegenseitig bestärken aber eins ist
natürlich das Internet kommt in unser
aller Leben an und damit eben auch
zunehmend diese Flutung von schlechten
Nachrichten ne und unser Gehirn kann
nicht unterscheiden
bin ich jetzt in Hamburg oder bin ich in
gaserstadt ich sehe die Bilder mein
Gehirn denkt das passiert bei mir um die
Ecke gleichzeitig haben wir im Bundestag
nimmt ab die Debatte zur Zukunft also
gibt's eine langfristige zuk eine Studie
von der Zukunftsfabrik die ganz deutlich
zeigt dass 50er 60er 70er 80er 90er
Jahre alles was zum Thema Zukunft ne
also das Wort Zukunft die Zeithorizonte
und so weiter wird alles ständig
debattiert Bundestag und im Jahr 2000
schmiert es irgendwie ab dann reden wir
worüber n noch über die über die
Gegenwart si und dann sieht ja und das
sieht man ja auch an den Slogans in der
Politik ja und gleichzeitig dann haben
wir noch irgendwie den Siegeszug der
Demokratie Stichwort des
wohlstandsversprechen also eigentlich
ist die Zukunft in Deutschland im Jahr
2000 in dem Sinne gestorben dass sie
nicht mehr als Möglichkeitsraum von was
anderem wahrgenommen wurde sondern das
gleiche wie heute aber vielleicht mehr
ja und ich glaube das ist das Problem
dass die Politik ne also es muss nicht
alles super sein damit man optimis
Optimist ist ne also also Deutschland
Hel der 50er helde des Optimismus waren
die 50er Jahre als gleichzeitig alle
gedacht haben ein Atomkrieg in meinem
Leben ist noch sehr wahrscheinlich aber
gleichzeitig waren alle damit
beschäftigt das Land wieder aufzubauen
Technologien Innovation und so weiter
und so weiter wir brauchen die man kann
in einer Krise durchaus zukunftsfähig
sein aber wir brauchen auch eine Politik
die was anderes anbietet als das
wohlstandsversprechen und ich glaube da
sind wir jetzt an dem Punkt wo wir uns
entwickeln weg von haben und hin zu sein
also ne was will ich in meiner Zukunft
nicht will ich noch mehr haben in 10
Jahren sondern will ich vielleicht
einfach glücklicher sein als heute und
das sieht man ja auch an z. von da
gibt's von der Uni Harvard eine
Langzeitstudie äh zu also happiness
glücklich sein und es ist tatsächlich
nicht wie viel hat man wie viel Autos
und Handy und was weiß ich sondern was
für Beziehungen hat man und das ist z.B
was das verspricht kein Politiker in
Deutschland dass es wichtig ist was für
Beziehungen man hat oder wie ist man ein
glücklicherer Mensch wie hat man wir
haben ja auch viel mehr Depression als
ja oder wie sind sie glückere Menschen
ich weiß nicht vielleicht auf jeden Fall
ich glaube das irgendwas irgendwas ist
da im Jahr 2000 bei uns verloren
gegangen und zwar auch in der Politik
sie sagen man kann messen wie oft den
politischen Programmen das Wort Zukunft
nicht me linguistisch genau seit dem
Jahr 2000 im Bundestag wird es wird die
Zukunft nicht mehr debattiert hat man ja
auch gesehen den letzten landtagswah si
man auch in den Wahlslogans natürlich an
eiglich immer die Gegenwart versprochen
also ich sag immer so grob also die die
Volksparteien bieten immer die Gegenwart
an mehr von heute also gleich wie heute
aber vielleicht ein bisschen mehr dann
haben wir die die Vergangenheit das ist
klassischerweise AFD und Linke und dann
die Zukunft eng besiedelt von den Grünen
und der FDP die versprechen eine
glorreiche Zukunft die Menschen die die
am die Versprechen keine glorreiche
Zukunft aber die Menschen die die
Zukunft für gestaltbar halten wählen
entweder grün oder FDP Herr Laguna sie
sind können sie mal erklären was sie
genau machen sie sind zuständig in
Deutsch sch für Zukunft kann man das so
unterbrechen im Auftrag der Regierung
genau deswegen muss man sagen es gibt
hier und da doch welche die es
verstanden haben dass das ging 2017 los
als die damalige Regierung das noch
beschlossen hat und 2019 hat man mich
berufen und seitdem versuche ich das
Institut für Bock auf Zukunft aufzub
aber sie sind zuständig für das ist ein
sehr schönes Wort der Chef der Agentur
für sprunginnovation ja genau die
Agentur für sprunginnovation oder Sprint
kurz eine sprunginnovation ist eine die
die Welt in einen davor und danach
unterteilt die das Leben der Menschen
besser machen seit wann seit wann gibt
es wir haben das 1871 Gründerzeit ein
paar mal richtig gut gemacht da war ich
nicht dabei ich habe das nachgelesen da
haben wir Forschung und Entwicklung in
die Welt gebracht und Industrien gemacht
die unser Leben besser gemacht
habgründung Soz ja das war ganze
chemische Industrie pharmainustrie g
heute ist das häufig ein Synonym für was
Schlechtes aber ehrlich das hat unseren
Wohlstand begründet das macht uns
gesünder und so weiter da ist viel Gutes
passiert wir haben nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg das wieder aufgebaut und schön
inkrementell verbessert
Automobilindustrie kommt auch daher
inkrementell heiß sozagen im wir sind
Weltmeister darin so die ganz Kleinen
der Diesel der noch
mal Schummel jetzt schaffen wir nicht
mehr aber den den den großen Sprung
sozusagen die disruption macht das alte
kaputt und stattdessen machen wir jetzt
alles elektrisch oder was auch immer da
sind wir schlecht da sind wir schlecht
weil das natürlich häufig so ist dass
man in diesen fahrtabhängigkeiten hängt
und da nicht mehr rauskommt das haben
wir beim Diesel oder beim Verbrenner
gesehen wir erfinden immer noch tolle
Sachen also ganz viele Technologien die
dann auch in die Welt kommen aber leider
durch andere die Welt gebracht werden
Amerika China ich meine ki ki also da
haben wir hier
die so kann man nicht sagen globale
Technologie wir haben aber hervorragende
Wissenschaftler und Wissenschaftlerinnen
die auch immer noch aber die haben eben
nicht open ai gegründet ne und wenn man
sich anschaut die let ganz kurz ist die
Firma die für Jet gptpt macht und die
jetzt irgendwie 100 Milliarden wert ist
von heute auf morgen schon mal Geld
verdient wer die haben schon mal Geld
verdient ne aber die Gründer die haben
Geld verdient also und Microsoft
verdient damit wahrscheinlich Geld ne
weil sie sich Sel hat nie Geld verdient
na das kommt auff an wie man Geld
verdienen definiert mit Umsatz minus
Kosten wie man das klassisch berechnet
nein da sind die noch weit von entfernt
das kann aber ganz schnell gehen das das
werden wir sehen ne ob ob s überhaupt
müssen ist eine andere Frage ob sie es
vielleicht vorher von Microsoft oder so
übernommen werden aber das nicht der
Punkt die Industrie nur kannz sie dürfen
sofort weiter ich w es nur einmal gerne
verstehen open ai die
Zukunftstechnologie KI Chat GPT und so
weiter die haben noch nie Geld verdient
nee nein die verbrennen die sehr viel
Geld das ist die investieren in Wachstum
ne die müssen jetzt ja sich ich weiß die
Microsoft 10 Milliarden das ist vor
allen Dingen dass sie Rechnerkapazitäten
von Microsoft verballern dürfen weil die
das ohne Ende brauchen wenn Linus ne das
beantworten müsste wie eine
Größenordnung zu kriegen ich ich glaube
letztes Jahr haben die eine halbe
Milliarde unterm Strich Verlust gemacht
obwohl
ihn viel an Rechnerkapazität quasi
kostenlos gespendet
wurde aber das ist verhältnismäßig wenig
Verlust wenn man sich überlegt was die
gebaut haben ne also natürlich muss eine
ähm
Innovation die wenn die jetzt kostenlos
mit wenig Aufwand so käme eine
sprunginnovation die da ja potenziell
gelungen ist dann hät dann wäre ja
früher gekommen ja oder oder bei jemand
anders aus Versehen also natürlich
mussten die müssen die Geld investieren
in diese Technologie ähm jetzt war auch
quasi nicht von vorne rein der ziel
dieser dieses Unternehmens viel Geld zu
machen sondern im Gegensatz eben diese
Innovationen herbeizuführen und ich
glaube die brauchen sich jetzt auch
keine Gedanken mehr darüber zu machen ob
sich das investierte Geld gelohnt hat
ich ich will nur Herr Laguna deswegen
habe ich sie gerade so so abrupt
unterbrochen darauf hinaus
auch Tesla z.B die haben ja auch ich
erinnere mich das Klagen von Aktionären
was für ein böser böser geldverbrenner
Elon Musk ist ja der die jahrelang
Milliarde um Milliarde verbrannt son
genau
dasselbe Jeff besos musste sich
jahrelang V seinen Aktionären
rechtfertigen weil am Ende nie was übrig
blieb der Amazon Gründer das heißt gibt
es sozusagen das sind alles
amerikanische Unternehmen über die wir
sprechen gibt es dort was Zukunft angeht
was die den Glaube an Zukunft angeht
eine andere Bereitschaft richtig in die
Vollen zu gehen und zu sagen egal alles
all in wie der Amerikaner sagt und wir
nicht ja also ja und die die legen auch
ihr Geld dahin wo ihr Glaube ist ne da
werden halt viele 10 Milliarden auf den
Tisch gelegt und so eine eine
Risikotechnologie ins Leben gebracht ne
und so macht man sprunginnovation also
mein Spruch mit 1870 das kommt daher
dass eine Innovation erst eine ist wenn
sie sich in der Welt entfaltet und ihre
Auswirkungen hat das ist bei uns in
Deutschland und in Europa wahnsinnig
schwierig gerade für die großen Sprünge
genügend Geld zu bekommen und der ST
Gens sie mit ihrer
sprungitprungagentur hätte ich jetzt
fast gesagt sie wie viel Geld haben sie
zur Verfügung für diese Sprung
Innovation rich wir Bau wir bauen es
gerade auf es dauert ja ein bisschen
dieses Jahr haben wir so um die 170
Millionen investiert in solche
Investitionen im ganzen Jahr im ganzen
Jahr ja das ist aber schon pro Jahr
nicht schlecht wenn man bedenkt dass es
uns operativ eigentlich noch nicht mal
dre Jahre lang gibt ne wir müssen ja
auch die Strukturen aufbauen um das zu
können aber wir müssen uns an unseren
Vorbildern orientieren die es da in
Amerika gibt als staatliche Organisation
das sind die Advanced project research
agencies die Aras da gibt's eine da das
ist Defense dann gibt's eine AR health
AR energy
das zusammenzählen und mal nur den
zivilen teilnehmen nicht das
militärische müssten wir so 1,2 bis 1,4
Milliarden pro Jahr investieren und das
ist das Zehnfache und da mussen wir da
werden n nicht mehr ganz ne nächst sind
wir so bei 220 230 Millionen schon also
wir kommen der Sache näher aber es hängt
natürlich immer davon ab wie viel der
Staat bereit ist ein Geld in diese
Zukunft zukunftsmaschine sozusagen zu
bringen und jetzt noch mal zu zu ihrer
Arbeit zu dem was sie tun also Sie woran
arbeiten sie gerade also an den großen
Fragen der Zeit ne über die wir hier
diskutieren also wenn wir wenn wir
uns mit dem Klimawandel beschäftigen
wollen müssen wir Technologien die den
Klimawandel adressieren in die Welt
bringen das heißt wir müssen wirklich
Windkraft ausbauen müssen Solar ausbauen
aber wir müssen auch in Zukunft
Technologien wie die Fusion die
Kernfusion die das ein für alle Mal
lösen könnte investieren ob die je
klappt wissen wir nicht keine Ahnung
aber wenn sie klappt deswegen sollten
wir uns auch nicht drauf verlassen dass
sie glaut ne genau deswegen ich sag ja
wind solar ausbauen
langzeitenergiespeichern alles Projekte
die wir machen übrigens ne sind die die
wir brauchen um klimaneutrales
Energiesystem herzustell aber das eine
das eine tun das andere nicht lassen ist
wichtig ne also wir machen longterm
energy also langzeitenergiespeicher
Challenge wir machen wir bauen das
höchste Windrad der Welt mit der 300 m
Nabenhöhe die war als zweite Etage in
existierende Windparks bauen können habe
ich hab neulich gelesen das machen sie
sie haben eins haben ich schon stehen
wir bauen eins das steht nächstes Jahr
wir haben den windmessturm gebaut der
ist 300 m hoch um zu validieren was da
rauskommt wir haben festgestellt
dreifacher energienge kann man da ernten
mit denselben gener atoren und man kann
es in die zweite Etage dreifache das
heißt du holst es insgesamt dann Faktor
4 aus demselben Windpark raus den du
einfach eine zweite Etage verpas das
sind Dinge die werden wir nächstes Jahr
sehen da ist das technologierisiko
überschaubar aber es sind eben
Komponenten einer Lösung ne das andere
ist mikroplastik aus dem Wasser entfernt
mit kleinen Luftbläschen wie machen sie
das wie geht das Plastik mag Wasser
nicht und heftet sich gerne an kleine
Luftbläschen wir machen Mikro kleine
Luftbläschen wirklich kleine Dinger
kleiner als ein haardurchmesser machen
daraus ein Sch den wir unten ins Wasser
einbringen das Plastik heftet sich an
die Luftbläschen kommt oben raus und da
können wir es abschöpfen das können wir
in die Gewässer bringen in die Flüsse
bringen wo das meiste reinkommt wir
können es in die Kanalisation bringen
wir können es in die Kläranlagen bringen
damit es gar nicht erst eingebracht wird
aber wir können es auch rausholen aus
kann skalalieren das kann man großen
Maßstab machen das kannst Du quasi in
verursachungsgerecht anbringen ne da da
wo es entsteht auf den straßenabrieb von
Reifen und so in den Kläranlagen du
kannst es in die Flüsse bringen damit es
nicht in die Meere kommt man kann es in
den Meeren einsetzen und da rauszolen da
wird's aber grob also man sollte es
möglichst vorher machen das sind alles
einzelne Technologien wir müssen da aus
allen Rohren feuern sozusagen weil wir
haben keine Zeit es ist ein riesen
Problem es sind Technologien die
durchaus da sind ob das mit der Fusion
mal je klappt oder nicht we will see wir
sind da recht optimistis Kernfusion da
gibt's auch wieder zehn
Technologieansätze die müssen wir alle
ausprobieren weil jetzt saubere grüne
Energie im Überfluss überall verfügbar
würde wahnsinnig viele Probleme auf
einmal lösen und das würde besser
skalieren als jetzt Windräder und Solar
skalalier aber das dürfen wir trotzdem
nicht bleiben lassen in der Medizin
dasselbe krebsheilen Alzheimer heilen
Breitband antivirale Wirkstoffe wir
haben schon noch genug Probleme und
genug Substanz für zukunftsversprechen
ne also ich findde das super wenn
Alzheimer Weg ist ne das ist eine
Zukunft die ich mir vorstellen kann V
ich kommen der Sache ja näher ne
irgendwie und jeder glaube ich hat das
in seiner Verwandtschaft das sind alles
Themen die die Sprint macht kann man auf
der sprint.org ne also sprunginnovation
Deutschland heißt sprint.org
nachlesen welche Ministerien sind für
sie zuständig augenblck sind es das
Bildungsministerium das
Wirtschaftsministerium also bmwk und fr
und stark Watzinger aber das werden
gerade
auch jetzt kommt Florence gaup und sagt
ja ja ja aber wenn zu viel Zukunft auf
einmal passiert gehen die Leute nicht
mehr mit haben die keinen Bock drauf
aber ich meinte nicht mein aber nicht
Laguna
nein aber prinzipiell und das ist ja
auch so ein Gefühl über das wir in dem
Zusammenhang auch mal reden müssen viele
Leute fühlen sich überf
pass auf immer dies Vorschriften diese
neuen Sachen ich komme da nicht mehr mit
also es gibt ein Buch aus den 70er das
Future shock und das hat es eigentlich
so ganz gut beschrieben also schon in
70er Jahren das Buch zum Teil recht zum
Teil Unrecht sie kennen es bestimmt aber
das ist schon ganz Antich beschreibt es
wenn zu viele Veränderungen gleichzeitig
passieren dann ist es für den Menschen
einfach zu viel der Mensch ist ein
Gewohnheitstier und er möchte gerne dass
einfach so viel wie möglich genauso
bleibt wie immer und jetzt haben wir ein
bisschen wie in den 70er Jahren haben
wir einen sozialen Wertewandel haben
einen umweltwandel haben einen
geopolitischen Wandel ähm also die 70er
Jahren war waren auch unglaublich also
Stichwort polykrise auch unglaublich
anstrengend also ein der erste
amerikanische Präsident der zurücktrett
eine ganze amerikanische Botschaft die
im Iran in Geiselhaft genommen wird äh
dann hatten wir natürlich riesen
Inflation wir hatten Energiekrise also
nicht ganz unähnlich eigentlich die 70er
Jahre und so ein bisschen ist es jetzt
auch also wir haben einen Wertewandel
sei es jetzt wenn es um wie was man ist
wen man liebt äh wie man heiraten will
und wie geopolitisch weitergeht und dann
auch noch das Klima und das ist das das
wo die Leute dann zum Teil einfach
abschalten und sagen das ein das
Kassandra Phänomen wie die griechische
Figur ne die die warmt vor den
schlechten Nachrichten und wird nicht
ernst genommen von H keiner mehr zu ganz
alch hör ir ker g genau wenn man die
Menschen überfordert mit mit mit mit mit
Veränderung und vor allem mit negativer
Veränderung das ist einfach kognitiv das
passiert im Gehirn quasi automatisch
dann sagt man nee kein Bock also so
Stichwort Rauchen ne man kann den Leuten
noch so viele Zigarettenschachteln mit
krebskranken Menschen drauf zeigen es
wird trotzdem weiter geraucht warum weil
das Gehirn kann es perfekt ausblenden
sie sind der Psychologe sie können es
noch besser als ich beschreiben und das
ist das ein bisschen was wir gerade
sehen also es gibt Leute wie hern Laguna
es gibt auch Leute wie mich gibt viele
Leute die da positiv dran arbeiten aber
ich würde schon sagen dass jetzt so in
der breiten Masse hat sich in der
Bevölkerung so diese dieses Gefühl
eingestellt so man kann ja eh nicht
machen und es ist alles zu viel und da
muss ich sagen da werde ich wirklich
wild ja wir leben in einer der reichsten
Demokratien der Welt ich kann mit mein
den aktuell Haushalt anguck ich mir
nicht sicher aber aber doch verglichen
mit anderen Stichwort Indien ja oder
oder oder oder Niger also ich kann ich
darf wählen gehen ich darf meine Meinung
sagen ich darf mein Verhalten ändern
mein Konsumverhalten ich habe Einfluss
ich habe fast das Gefühl es ist so eine
hyperindividualisierung eingetreten so
nach dem Motto also wenn ich jetzt nicht
alleine den Klimawandel ändern kann na
dann ist das wahrscheinlich ich nicht
nicht zu nicht zu verändern ich glaub
dieses kollektive
hyperindividualisierung sagen sie sie
meinen das istagen ein ein könnte ein
ein Grund ein Hinweis sein ein saglicher
auf die Frage woher das kommt könnte ein
Baustein sein weil eigentlich fast alle
dieser Probleme können im Kollektiv ja
durchaus angegangen werden das wir sind
zu egoistisch oder individualistisch
also so nach dem Motto sie
formulierenal sch es gibt es gibt ja
eine Studie die zeigt in den 80er Jahren
dachten so ich glaube 10% der Leute ja
ich bin was besonderes heutzutage denken
das 80% der Leute ernsthaft ja wirklich
also das das zeigt doch noch mal in den
80ern dachten das also es gibt es gibt
eine langzeitstulle da fragte man die
Leute denken sie sind was besonderes und
das war halt damals eine Minderheit und
heute denkt jeder er ist was besonderes
also wenn jeder denkt er ist was
besonderes dann denkt er natürlich auch
also wenn ich das Problem nicht lösen
kann dann kann es vielleicht niemand
also es ist ein bisschen überspitzt
formuliert aber eigentlich sie sind
jetzt ein Beispiel von jemand der sich
engagiert im Kollektiv aber die meisten
Leute Teilen vielleicht ihren Frust aber
denken sich ach dann schicke ich doch
ein Tweet ab die Sache ist geritzt aber
twitter ist nicht die Straße twitter ist
nicht eine Demonstration Twitter geht
nicht wählen exung Ex heißt das jetzt
das ja interessant also sozusagen wir
wir finden uns einfach alle zu großartig
Karla resm na sie ja nicht weil sie ist
ja aktiviert ne aber sie sie kennt ja
nun viele viele Leute aus ihrer
Generation W keine Altersfrage oder so
habe ich das verstanden genau keine
Altersfrage alle finden wir müssen nicht
die jungen schämen D die älteren denken
das auch sind was besonderes ja ich
kenne viele ältere die sich
unangeschränkt wirklich ganz grandios
finden ja das ist
so aber aber ist das das Thema und dass
wir deswegen also was sie ja beschreiben
ist ja im Grunde so ein ja schon ein
Egoismus oder eine Egozentrik die daraus
resultiert und die dann dazu führt dass
wir nicht bereit sind zu sagen pass auf
für das große Ganze müssen wir ein
bisschen zurücktreten und dann lösen wir
das
gemeinsam ich glaube dass wir da einmal
den Schritt zurück machen müssen weil
ich glaube dass die Frage ist ja schon
was ist eigentlich dieses große Ganze
über was wir sprechen weil es ist total
begründet dass sich Leute Angst haben
vor der Klimakrise weil es ist sie wird
kommen
die Frage ist wie schlimm wird sie
kommen aber wir haben es erlebt wir
haben alle Studien und zahlen die sagen
selbst mit den ambitioniertesten
Klimazielen die international gerade da
sind haben wir Ende des Jahrhunderts 3°
klimaerhitzung und das heißt dann
Hitzewellen Waldbrände Überflutung
hungerslöte in dem Ausmaß was wir uns
jetzt gerade noch gar nicht vorstellen
können und da ist es sehr sehr
berechtigt Angst vor zuaben und im
nächsten Schritt erleben wir aber ja
eine große Sorge vor der Veränderung die
notwendig wäre um was gegen die
Klimakrise zu tun und anstatt bei dieser
begründeten Angst vor der Klimakrise
anzusetzen und daraus politisch eine
Handlungsmacht irgendwie abzuleiten und
zu sagen ja wir nehmen diese Veränderung
in die Hand haben wir gerade eine
Politik die so ein
wohlfühlfortschrittsversprechen macht
und sagt na klar wir transformieren
jetzt die gesamte Gesellschaft
klimaneutral aber ihr merkt davon alle
nichts und wir tun so als wir tut euch
nicht weh heißtz ne gen genau wir wollen
NS nichts zumuten das geht alles so
genau das ist business as usual niemand
merkt was davon Robert habck macht das
vielleicht ein bisschen in seinem
Ministerium und vielleicht ist es so ein
Randphänomen für irgendwie so ein paar
Ökos oder so eine Gesellschaftsgruppe
und politisch wird uns gerade erzählt
dass die Klimakrise keine
gesamtgesellschaftliche Aufgabe wäre
weil wir können Sie einfach mit business
as usual und ein bisschen
technologischen Fortschritt lösen und
das ist aber massiv gescheitert das
haben wir ja spätestens dieses Jahr
gesehen eine Gesellschaft wird nicht
einfach so klimaneutral ohne dass wir
dafür große Veränderung irgendwie haben
die Leute auch mitbekommen und das heißt
wir müssen genau darüber reden und ich
glaube daran scheitert gerade auf der
einen Seite die Politik sie hat
theoretischerweise den Zuspruch von
Leuten die sagen Klima ist ihnen total
wichtig da ist seit Jahren sagen die
Studien 80 90% der Leute halten die
Klimakrise für ein groß das problemch
und wollen dass die Regierung mehr tut
die Politik schafft es aber nicht eine
Erzählung und eine Antwort darauf zu
finden wie man dann mit dieser Krise
umgeht W man das übersetzt in Zustimmung
zu Maßnahmen und da glaube ich ist es
natürlich auch was wo wir irgendwie als
klimabewegte Menschen irgendwie drauf
schauen und sagen hey das haben wir auch
noch nicht geschafft so wir haben es
über die letzten Jahre geschafft ein
ganz ganz große Bewusstsein dafür
herzustellen wir haben gesehen irgendwie
keine Partei keine Institution keine
Talkshow kommt mir daran vorbei
irgendwie um sich mit dem Thema Klima
auseinanderzusetzenm wie das jetzt aber
konkret aussieht und wie wir aus der
Angst vor der Klimakrise nicht eine
Angst vor Veränderung machen sondern
eine positive Veränderung haben und
sagen wie kann das denn aussehen ohne in
so ein naives fortschrittsversprechen zu
fallen was irgendwie sagt ja klar das
löst sich alles weil das wäre der
Situation nicht angemessen das ist
glaube ich der Punkt wo wir hin müssen
und wo auch dieses ganze diese Hof also
wo wo wo wir nicht hoffnungslos werden
dürfen weil es gibt ja noch Grund zur
Hoffnung weil wir können Dinge tun wie
sie das sagen gibt da noch Grund zu
hoffen wei alles gut alles gut tut das
in der Seele weh ich immer denke man ihr
seid junge Leute und wenn ihr nicht an
die Zukunft glaubt also ich habe keine
Zeit me zu glauben wen ich nicht nicht
sitzen also ich weiß ich weiß ich will
nur sagen das ist es ist hat irgendwie
was irgendwie was trauriges und das
merke ich immer auch in Gesprächen mit
mit wirklich vertret ihrer sehr jungen
Generation die sind die sind alle so die
die sind sich das ist ja genau das Thema
Glaube an eine gute Zukunft der ist
nicht mehr sehr ausgeprägt na ja also
das ist ja auch berechtigt also dass
junge Leute Ich find weil das wird ja
jetzt so getan wenn Sie sich hier
hinstellen und sagen und die wollen alle
nicht mehr und wahrscheinlich wollen wir
auch alle keine Innovation mehr machen
und niemand will mehr forschen also da
würde ich jetzt gerne mal kurz PL
ergreifen es gibt Grund warum junge
Leute aber aber was ganz interessant ist
junge Leute in armen Ländern Glauben
durchaus dass die Klimakrise zu
bewältigen ist also da gibt es schon ein
europäisches Ph fomen im Pessimismus
gerade also junge Leute sowieso aber
auch junge Leute Also es geht noch nicht
mal ums woh
wohlstandsversprechenichwort Indien
jetzt wieder warum eigentlich Indien es
könnte auch ir anderes Land sein aber
tatsächlich ist so dass z. auch in China
oder in afrikanischen Ländern junge
Menschen glauben ja der Klimawandel ist
real aber wir können das schaffen und
ich glaube das ist da dieses wir können
das schaffen warum ist es weg oder warum
ist es aktuell nicht da und es ist nicht
nur ein deutsches Phänomen es ist ein
europäisches Phänomen aber es ist in
anderen Ländern tatsächlich nicht so
verbreitet wie bei uns aber dann ja dann
schauen wir uns doch mal die letzten
Jahre an und warum irgendwie junge Leute
vielleicht auch das Gefühl haben dass
die Politik keine ernsthaften Antworten
findet gucken wir nur zurück bis zur
coronapandemie wo wir erlebt haben so
Schülerinnen Studierende Auszubildende
waren das wo es Leute am wenigsten
interessiert hat wo es immer hieß wir
machen jetzt was und dann gab es dre
Jahre lang online Uni dann gab's
jahrelang online Schule was wirklich ein
Konzept ist was vorne und hinten nicht
aufgeht das weiß jeder der irgendwie mit
Kindern arbeitet das funktioniert nicht
jetzt in der Energiekrise waren die
Studierenden die als allerletztes
irgendwie in energiepreishilfen bekommen
hab stimmt alles das stimmt alles aber
es gibt junge Menschen die in Diktaturen
leben die die die unseren Wohlstand
nicht haben die nicht diesen Pessimismus
Teilen deswegen ich sag
ursachenforschung ist eine Sache aber es
gibt auch ein kulturelles Phänomen